coup d'envoi de la cop27 qui débute
aujourd'hui en Egypte avec près de 100
chefs d'État et de gouvernement réunis
dont le président français et derrière
il faut qu'on ait des États-Unis et la
Chine qui soit vraiment au rendez-vous
notre bataille c'est que les plus riches
soient là qui payent leur juste part et
là-dessus soyons aussi clair j'ai besoin
qu'on se dise des choses les Européens
paient on est mais simplement le
problème c'est qu'on est les seuls à
payer le président Macron va sûrement
encore une fois faire un beau discours
il va se fouetter 10 fois en disant
tellement on est responsable du
dérèglement climatique tellement c'est
grave dans le même temps nous voyons
nombre de nos états qui sont frappés par
les conséquences même du dérèglement
climatique et qui si besoin en été nous
démontre une fois encore que l'urgence
climatique est bien là elle n'est pas
pour demain et je vous le donne en mille
il y avait un spectacle pour sauver la
planète
mais oui
19 et pas un degré de plus à Toulouse
les écoles de la ville devront passer
l'hiver un peu plus au frais pour
réduire les coûts du chauffage en
parallèle les actions des militants
écolosse multiplient encore ce matin les
militants de dernière rénovation bloqué
une partie du périphérique parisien au
niveau du 14e arrondissement ils se sont
assis pour bloquer la circulation vous
avez des jeunes qui un visage découvert
un visage découvert disent attention
notre avenir est en train d'être
sacrifié nous sommes désespérés de la
situation dans laquelle nous sommes il y
a l'inaction climatique en permanence 8
milliards d'habitants sur terre un cap
qui sera passé le 15 novembre prochain
selon les Nations unies la population
mondiale qui a bondit en moins d'un
siècle en 1950 la terre comptait en
effet 2 milliards et demi d'individus
c'est un Hidalgo qui a twitté ceci il y
a quelques allez une poignée d'heures
dérèglement climatique énergétique et
inflation touche toutes les villes
l'état refuse d'être à leur côté pour
garder les services publics nous n'avons
d'autres choix dit tels que d'augmenter
la taxe foncière entre temps on s'est
renseigner elle va passer de 13,5 à 20%
le papillon coûte est fini et nous
allons vers des aides qui seront plus
ciblées c'est-à-dire qui toucheront les
personnes qui ont le plus besoin les
ménages qui sont le plus touchés par
l'inflation les prix alimentaires les
prix de l'énergie les prix des
carburants comme souvent avec Madame
Hidalgo l'état abondo moi je veux
rappeler que depuis plusieurs années
l'État a accompagné très fortement la
ville de Paris les Parisiens 5 milliards
pendant la crise covid un bouclier
tarifaire sur les billets de train le
gouvernement demande à la SNCF de
limiter la hausse des prix sur les TGV
et les Intercités il y a quelques jours
seulement encore on a fait un versement
exceptionnel de 50 millions d'euros de
recettes de TVA à la ville de Paris mais
à un moment donné c'est vrai que l'État
ne veut pas combler la sens de gestion
de la ville de Paris face à la flambée
des prix de l'énergie les billets la
SNCF a fait ses calculs sa facture
d'électricité va grimper de 600 millions
d'euros cette année il est où
aujourd'hui Grégoire
mais vous êtes sûr qu'il est pas là
c'est pas vous qui lui avait demandé
pardon
à ce livre et je pense qu'il y a surtout
pas envie de vous vous croisez puisque
vous êtes obsédé par ça on entend ici ou
là que les discussions qu'il a c'est
avec par exemple des gens de chez
Zemmour
je n'ai pas eu un coup de fil depuis un
an de Monsieur Bardella les proches
de rediabolisation je suis président par
intérim depuis depuis un an nous avons
obtenu cette année avec Marine Le Pen
des résultats qu'on n'avait jamais
obtenus dans l'histoire de notre
mouvement et si elle m'a confié des
responsabilités depuis 3 ans d'ailleurs
c'est parce qu'entre nous il y a une
vraie continuité idéologique je vais
vous dire je n'aurais même pas concédé
d'ailleurs comme Marine Le Pen une
maladresse parce que je ne vois pas ce
qu'il y a de maladroit et encore moins
évidemment de raciste c'est à dire que
des clandestins africains ou vocation à
retourner en Afrique des gens qui sont
spécialiser uniquement sur des questions
d'identité
oui parce que
il en faut mais voilà pas trop d'abord
surpris le reporter continue d'évoquer
la hausse des vols dans ce quartier
résidentiel de la capitale et en soudain
l'oiseau va lui donner raison et
[Musique]